at number 18 we head to Belarus for an
obsession with driver dashcams is
creating a surge of viral videos I think
this is the luckiest guy on the internet
by far see if you can guess what happens
next
this is the world's biggest fail become
the most amazing win I've ever seen ever
it's like he's some kind of stuntman
how does he pull off these Auto
acrobatics this guy's life was saved by
the laws of the universe
one of the major laws of physics is that
something that's moving it's gonna keep
moving in the same way unless some force
acts on it when that motorcycle hits
that car that's a major force and the
motorcycle stops dead but the rider
isn't attached so he continues traveling
forwards at the same speed and because
he has his hands on the motorbike
handles that acts as a pivot to flip him
over the front of the motorbike by the
time he's flipping through air he's
managed to slow down exactly the same
speed as the car the relative motion is
zero and that's what makes this very
lucky stunt possible turning a major
fail into a one-in-a-million win